all right
ice ice where'd you grow up are you from
originally
south central California South Central
LA and you grew up with both your pants
not necessarily it was a little cheeky
adopted
I had adoptive parents both my parents
was on crack both my your real parents
were both my grill pans for users yes so
how was your life with the doctor family
psyche is here it was it wasn't
something that was pleasant but it
wasn't something that was just all the
way down the drain if you understand
what I'm saying food um but for the most
part he was shaking his hair I didn't
get to spend much time with him my mama
always on at work nice shift working on
as a nurse as a LVN I'm a st. Francis
always going at nighttime sleep during
the daytime when I come home one from
whatever I'm doing running the streets
blase blase block school whatever the
case may be
Pop's was a rolling stone he was already
out the house and out the house adoptive
parents was Jamaican so I had a little
taste of a different culture but at the
same time is we living in LA so it's a
bunch of different ethnicities you got
Jamaicans Belizeans
yeah a lot of everybody what can I get
for your high school it's high school
did you guys go
somewhat wait everybody the gang life
company start being gang life started I
started being gang affiliated at eleven
that's when I really started getting the
trouble [ __ ] up [ __ ] jumping in the
houses stealing cars including my mama
car when I got the chance
yeah well I was just a badass little kid
I was you're serious and running around
between me getting kicked out and
running away just because I wanted to be
a part of the streets it's so you went
to Wyatts some point yeah why is a youth
30 yeah that's like basically jail
prison for kids right mmm-hmm prison for
kids came home 24 26 and then you went
out on your own
where'd you go [ __ ] I was actually
homeless you're homeless I was homeless
for a while when I got out I was
homeless running a street steal jobs
wasn't [ __ ] with me I'm a felon of
course so I just got to get it out the
mug do whatever I got to do sell this so
that robbed this robbed that you get it
however I can but it's like
we had this conversation so you know
it's like living in this environment we
have we forced to go out and go get it
you know it's not something else and
just provided for us like everybody else
yeah you didn't have use of a spoon you
grew up in Beverly Hills with a dad
who's a doctor her mom you know and the
width I'm sixteen with at Elsa and
iPhone iPhone 11 [ __ ] I didn't see a
mother [ __ ] what I've seen the church
at 12 but now is it yeah the
opportunities that you had limited limit
you and your possibilities are out there
from your limited
look at me I'm a tall dude I could have
been somewhere playing basketball the
football I'm good at both but you know
we know you never figure out where I
would have went did you have had any
role models as a kid that might have you
could have emulated and follow all the
role models around this was either on
the black or in jails and we couldn't
talk to the role models so it's like and
in the people that word the actual quote
unquote figure role models that we
should look up to we was too much of
knuckleheads or hoodlums or whatever the
case might be team for them to even sit
down and had a patience with us I look
this how you need to do things and shape
our leaders kids it was probably looking
at them to like [ __ ] I mean trying to
follow you you know you doing the dish
it I want to have fun and that's how
she'd go this is like the path is real
real real different we are different
there's a creek you're a creek right
yeah you've lost friends more friends
ain't even a word lost brothers
family is it's not just this ain't no
friendship this is this ain't just no
Brotherhood there's a brotherhood but
it's more than that it's way more than
that becomes your family right it
becomes your family you become tied in
with everybody you you didn't been
homeless with everybody you Thurmond you
in the hood you've dug in there with
everybody hey let me crash that show
spot
now you can't crash on my spot but I got
got a little something for you here damn
thank you bro I think it really need to
dish but oh what's the deal brother
blase blase glad we get into this
together
sure oh we go chop it up like man we
everybody didn't been through a whole
bunch of [ __ ] together and it's like
once the [ __ ] just gone they're gone
and a lot of people don't realize that
as far as the gangbanging goes do I
regret it you know what I change it no
but what I tell the next [ __ ] to
do it no because it's it's a lot of
loopholes now yeah like I'm even going
through some [ __ ] right now where I
can't really even go into details like
that like that way it'll be over bound
but it's you know gonna play get you
caught up and I'm going through some
[ __ ] right now so you're facing a murder
charge something along those lines and
man [ __ ] I'm easy but that'll change
your life forever forever either you
could be behind the fo-fo walls with a
whole bunch of [ __ ] taking showers
together well you could be our song
living life getting money [ __ ]
[ __ ] doing what you need to do
building your empire sue me because a
lot of people
man [ __ ] all the [ __ ] focus on
yourselves
is cameras everywhere
snitches everywhere everybody talking
it's don't my name business
there's the laws are harsher laws are
harsher especially California laws
especially California laws leagues don't
got no self-defense laws and it makes it
harder for us as the years have gone by
running like this what even nine years
ago when done like this nine eight even
go back six years ago ones really like
this but all our fuck-ups and all
honesty that's what it is all our
fuck-ups cuz it's just he got the white
man back on it's tough
[Applause]
but they don't realize that they put us
in this situation we've been put in this
situation by the white man to dig
ourselves out do you think the lack of
opportunity lack of hope that that you
guys had growing up the broken families
all that stuff as far as you just set up
set you up for failure I wouldn't say
that in a sense you we're gonna set up
for failure because I painted a day who
put them crates there who put the train
cars down here I lay with all the guns
and drugs
I really put all that here now you've
got a situation like myself cracked-out
parents now I'm missing out on the
relational relationship that I could
have had and I just met them recently
just recently and as far as recently I'm
saying this year where they don't
Inglewood they're living in a house
apartment
how Inglewood where is your biological
parents say to you more so just my mom
but they actually been cleaning for a
while and that was a surprise blessing
you know me been dealing with a whole
bunch of anger issues and mental issues
as well so I was diagnosed with
schizophrenia me not knowing that as a
kid for me and bipolar bipolar disorder
me not knowing that as a kid I'd snap on
everything and I had anger issues I was
elementary school I I thought stapler
had a kid head I got suspended on the
stapler had a kid here I was only in
third grade I got kicked out of
elementary school since you Park
Elementary and it's like all that [ __ ]
leads up to [ __ ] man
your environment is the biggest factor
and how you live your life you think
environments more powerful than family
environment plays a bigger factor than
family because my family could be going
to church doing everything that any fill
me is the right thing but I could be
going to school at the same time but
everybody I'm living in the hood
neighborhood and everybody in that
school this big you feel me
and then now I'm attracted to that now
it's like I just touched stuff is boring
I want to go have fun
so your environments gonna always
overpower think of a kid at Disneyland
they go to the food court they trippin
they don't really want no food they want
to be over here at the rides
there's no environment is everything you
could be with your family over here
eatin food now
cool come on let's go to here I'm gonna
get on doing Superman or whatever the
case might be
it's just different our lifes ain't the
same that's why I don't live by the
rules as much as I want to I see that's
not gonna give me no way but it's how
you play are you scared now for your
future
I'm always be straight but as far as
opportunities and future opportunities
I'll probably be missing out some I'll
probably be missing out on a lot if
you're the extended prison time football
numbers yeah mm-hmm football numbers man
probably love and probably the lower
football numbers but yeah it's not
looking too good China
if I'm a juggler lifestyle getting money
and doing all this it's a little high
you know how you playing with guys til
they're fast money ends up getting you
either long prison time or definitely if
either one of the other one or the other
yeah that's it ain't no other way around
it the judge ain't playing with nobody
DA's and DA's and wait you think just
because you got a paid lawyer that they
don't yo saw it don't think is it's
friends
it's lawyer mr. judge they you can
working on the same team so you just
wasted however much money do you just
use to put in this case I ain't that do
you feel like you get stereotyped as
because you're a young black man you're
you're gonna be assumed guilty even from
the from the start even by your lawyer
how's hope not you know they say creeps
don't got no religion nothing is no I'm
[ __ ] believe in God I believe God got a
[ __ ] I believe God got me in his best
interest and his favor you feel me so
she gonna be alright no matter what the
outcome is actually at the end of the
day I know what I did and one other
person know what I did and whatever
happened can't be taken back so stay in
school and don't do drugs keys
alright guys thank you so much for
talking with me no problem here and good
luck with whatever happens with your
case Nate
you